so I haven't seen you for any of
November so far which means you're in
for a bit of a shock I just like many
others have been attempting to
participate in Movember
this year and as a result I now have a
lack of self-confidence because I can't
grow a mustache any other month of the
year I wouldn't even want to grow a
mustache like I've done enough
photoshopping in my lifetime to know
that it probably wouldn't be a good look
on me but when Movember rolls around
like I do envy friends of mine who at
least like have a choice about whether
or not they want to participate in fact
I mean I envy them every other month of
the year as well it's not that I don't
want a beard
I just want to have you know beard
potential then of course friends of mine
who can grow beards but choose not to
end up envying me because I don't have
to shave as often so there's no real way
to win like if you are a guy and you
don't have facial hair it promptly means
you're unhappy no very nice realisation
really Johanna hug I do but there's got
to be a way too complicated with the
split screen so now though instead this
month I'm just going to participate in I
can't grow facial hair so I'm just gonna
donate a little bit of money to our
prostate cancer charity overbut and if
you're in a similar situation to me
maybe do the same and speaking of
slightly emasculating things I really
want a kitten I really want a kid but
annoyingly Emily and I went into a pet
rescue place just the other day to sign
up to get a kitten and they turned us
away because we live in an apartment
building we've been planning on getting
this kitten for ages now ever since like
before we moved into this place and like
as of this week we are fully prepared
for one I got a scratching post I got
the the feathery flyyy toy thingy
majiggy I got lots of food got a place
to eat the food got a place for it to
poop I've got all the the poop litter
stuff I got the poop scoop all the poop
stuff I even have catnip which is weird
actually because I didn't I didn't order
any catnip this just kind of came in the
package along with the scratching post
which makes me worried that I
participated in some like weird
black-market feline drug deal all of
this to say that I am by no means
anywhere near giving up on getting a
kitten just yet especially as we have
only been to the one pet rescue place so
far and there are many other cats
definitely live in this building and who
seemed perfectly happy to me so get it
perfectly happy cuz the cat pass in
happier news earlier this week I was
given the opportunity to record my very
own show on BBC Radio 1 which I know is
an opportunity that has been handed to
pretty much every other British vlogger
so far but it's a big deal for me coz
means somebody out there still thinks
I'm relevant Thank You mum it's going
out this Monday at 9 p.m. and recording
it was just about as nerve-racking as I
thought it would be so if you tuned in
and you hear somebody who sounds like
they might be about to faint
then you're on the right station that's
it from me I am planning on making my
next video a fun science one about time
so do please tune in for that set your
dial charlie is so cool like and I'll
see you next time good bye you've just
had the almost imponderable joy of
watching Charlie is so cool like which
makes you like cool Charlie McDonnell
BBC Radio 1 could we try cooking anyway
well fixing post thank you very much for
watching my most recent video was my new
short film our brother so if you find
yourself with a spare 20 minutes
it's a long and then do please take a
look at that thank you very much goodbye
once again and goodbye again and again
[Music]
if you're filming me then you better
release that good news